[APPLAUSE]
SARI KATZ: You want to
just come sit with me?
Yeah.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Which one?
You're over here?
SARI KATZ: I feel like
this is going to be
a little bit tough for me.
Let's see if I can do it.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yo,
let's hike her up.
SARI KATZ: I got it.
I got it.
Hi, everybody.
My name is Sari Katz, and
I am on the YouTube Content
Partnerships team.
It is my pleasure and absolute
honor to get to work with Gigi.
We've been working together
for like, what, two years?
GIGI GORGEOUS: I was
going to say three.
SARI KATZ: OK, maybe three.
Actually, you're right.
GIGI GORGEOUS:
Yeah, a long time.
SARI KATZ: You're right, and
you didn't remember this,
but the first time we
did an interview together
was May of 20--
what are we now, 2017?
So May 2014.
GIGI GORGEOUS: In Canada.
SARI KATZ: In Canada.
We're both Canadians.
Any proud-- yes, yes!
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yes!
SARI KATZ: Some proud
Canadians in the room!
GIGI GORGEOUS:
Now we're talking.
SARI KATZ: That's right.
That's right.
Everybody else can just leave.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah, exactly.
SARI KATZ: This is
a welcome space.
So yes, so I hope most,
if not all, of you
are familiar with the
lovely Gigi Lazzarato,
otherwise known
as Gigi Gorgeous.
If you're not, Gigi's got
almost, what, 3 million
subs on YouTube now?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Mhm.
SARI KATZ: That's right,
360 something million
views on her channel.
Gigi is a beacon of
positivity and beauty
and has been an incredible
inspiration to her fans
and the family at YouTube.
So we've already welcomed
her, but welcome, Gigi.
GIGI GORGEOUS:
Thanks for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
SARI KATZ: Yay.
So why don't we start off by
talking about your YouTube
channel?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Cool.
SARI KATZ: So what inspired
you to start on YouTube?
GIGI GORGEOUS: I was actually
really bored in high school.
I went to a Catholic school, so
I was in a uniform every day.
We only had one day out of the
month to dress how we wanted.
So I had a lot of creativity.
And I had actually just
stopped competitive diving.
I was national
champion in Canada.
So I was kind of like,
at the top of the game.
I was on the way
to the Olympics.
But I just fell out of
love with the sport.
I was just like, really, I
don't want to do this anymore.
So I quit, just
full turkey quit.
Everyone was like, oh my god.
What the hell?
What is she going
to do with her life?
So I was in high
school, socializing.
I finally had a social
life, because I was diving
all the time, practicing.
So I saw Michelle Phan, who
actually is a makeup artist.
And she is so talented.
She kills it.
And I saw her YouTube channel.
And I was like, I want
to start doing makeup.
So I stole my mom's makeup
and tested it out online.
And I kept on uploading.
I kept on growing,
as did the website.
SARI KATZ: Yep, yep.
Do you remember
your first video?
GIGI GORGEOUS: I do.
It was sitting on my bedroom
floor with my digital camera.
I think it was like, you
know, so old, not cute at all.
Couldn't see what I was doing.
And then I just put it online.
I forget what I edited with,
but I put it in the fastest
fast forward I could.
And then I put Rihanna's
"Disturbia," the song--
SARI KATZ: Uh oh.
GIGI GORGEOUS:
--behind it, which
was my favorite jam at the time.
And yeah, that was my first one.
And then I think I did
makeup collections.
Then it kind of
transitioned into lifestyle.
I started talking about my
life, what I was going through,
not just strictly makeup.
And now those are
my favorite videos
to do, sitting down and talking.
SARI KATZ: To do more
of the lifestyle?
Yep, I know.
I do love your story times.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Thanks.
SARI KATZ: If anyone's
not familiar, again,
go watch Gigi's channel.
It's amazing.
So nowadays, other
than your life,
where do you get
inspiration from?
Where do you come up
with all your ideas?
GIGI GORGEOUS: I've honestly--
I get inspiration everywhere.
I would say mostly from the
people I surround myself with.
My best friends, they're all
very creative and extroverts.
You know, we love just
creating random stuff.
My girlfriend-- in nature, if
I see a cute little flower,
I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
SARI KATZ: What about
other YouTubers?
Are there any really
inspirational YouTubers to you
now?
Who do you watch?
GIGI GORGEOUS:
Oh, I'm obsessed--
OK, well, she's not
really a YouTuber.
Her stuff is posted online.
But Wendy Williams--
I'm obsessed with her.
It sounds so silly, but
I just have to catch up
with her all the time.
I love Liz, obviously.
I love Casey.
SARI KATZ: Yes, Casey Neistat.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Casey's
really fun to watch.
Yeah, and it's not
anything up my alley,
but it's just fun to
see what he's up to.
And I've worked with
him before for Samsung.
SARI KATZ: Oh, yes.
I remember.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yes, which
I think is still a secret.
I don't know.
SARI KATZ: No, no, no.
Not anymore.
GIGI GORGEOUS: My bad.
I love other story
times on YouTube.
I think it's really fun.
Yeah, I honestly
really watch everybody.
I'm like, subscribed
to everybody.
And I just scroll
through and watch.
SARI KATZ: There's so much.
What about if you could
choose one person that
doesn't have a YouTube channel?
Who would you wish
to start a channel?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Hm,
that's a good one.
I would say, honestly, for
anyone that's watched my film,
everyone's obsessed with my dad.
So like, they're like,
oh my god, I really
want your dad to have a
Twitter or an Instagram.
And I'm like, he's 50 plus.
He's not trying to do all that.
But I would love my dad
to have a YouTube, just
because he has inspired
so many parents out there.
And I'm sure he has a
shit ton of questions
that he could get asked and
he could answer and help
the world.
SARI KATZ: We will get to more
of your dad later tonight.
Because if you
haven't seen the film,
I'm not going to say he's like--
GIGI GORGEOUS: He's
the star of the show.
[LAUGHS]
We're just going to say it.
He really is.
SARI KATZ: But no, he is also
just totally inspirational.
And again, we'll get to that.
But he's a wonderful,
wonder-- and in person, he's
just wonderful human being too.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah,
he's a sweetheart.
SARI KATZ: What about
the impact that YouTube
has had on your life?
So you've had a major impact
on a ton of people's lives.
And we'll get to that.
But what about the impact
that YouTube as a platform
has had on your life?
GIGI GORGEOUS: It's had
a huge impact on my life.
I don't think that I wouldn't
be where I'm at right now
without the website.
Because I feel like
in my life growing up,
I knew that I was different.
And I always felt like I
was different or special
in a way, rather
than the other people
at my school, or my family, or
my best friends, or whatever.
And I think that
YouTube worked as kind
of like a little bit
of a therapist for me
without me knowing it.
I would just talk about
what I was going through,
answer questions from people.
But in turn, it
was really helping
my growth and my
being self aware.
And I think YouTube does
that for a lot of people,
unconsciously.
It just happens, because
you really are expressing,
and you're talking,
and you're engaging.
And it definitely helped
me with my transition,
because it held me accountable.
When I put up that video
saying that I am transgender,
it was kind of just my telling
the world, telling my family,
telling everybody
that watched the video
that this is who I am.
And I was to be held accountable
for it, which it really,
really helped in that sense.
SARI KATZ: Yeah, do
you go back and watch--
do you go watch those videos?
GIGI GORGEOUS: I
really don't, no.
SARI KATZ: No?
GIGI GORGEOUS: No.
I feel like I made
so many mistakes
along the way with things I
said, things I joked about.
It's just kind of cringe worthy.
So I just keep it moving.
SARI KATZ: Keep moving forward?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah.
SARI KATZ: But again, all
learnings, like you said.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Totally.
SARI KATZ: OK, that's good.
GIGI GORGEOUS: No regrets.
SARI KATZ: No regrets.
GIGI GORGEOUS: But don't
want to harp on it.
[LAUGHING]
SARI KATZ: Fair enough.
So to someone that hasn't seen
your channel-- which again,
I'm sure everybody has--
how would you
describe your channel?
How would you describe
the Gigi Gorgeous brand?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Honestly,
I'd just say my brand,
or my channel, is just my life.
I really, really don't
hold very much back.
Recently I've been
doing a lot of traveling
for the film, and for
vacations, and whatever.
And I've just
picked up the camera
and filmed my adventures.
And I feel like you really are
getting an inside look into me.
I think before, like in past
years, I was very proper,
and I would sit down
in front of the camera,
say what I had to say,
and then I'd check out.
But after the film
came out, I think
it's just-- we called it "This
Is Everything" two reasons.
Because it really is everything.
We're not holding anything back.
All facets of my life
are there for you
to see-- my family, everything,
the good, the bad, the ugly.
And now I feel like it's
just everyone knows who I am.
And I'm not trying
to hide anymore.
So sometimes you
get a makeup video.
Sometimes you get
a travel video.
Sometimes you get a
story time, whatever.
You know?
SARI KATZ: Yeah, no one can
ever say that you are not
being yourself.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah,
because I've always
said from the
beginning, anything fake
really never lasts very long.
So even if you are being fake
about something here or there,
I feel like people will
catch on and they'll see.
So even if people
don't like you,
just be real, because there's
going to be people who will.
And those are the people
you want to be around.
SARI KATZ: Yeah, absolutely.
That's the people you
surround yourself with.
What about how you engage
with your audience?
So obviously a huge
part of YouTube
is the fan culture,
social media in general.
So how do you engage with
your audience both online
and in real life?
GIGI GORGEOUS: My
audience and my supporters
and my consistent viewers
mean the world to me.
It is like profound
how much they
mean to me, because
they've helped me out
of some of the darkest
points in my life.
I don't even know
if I would be here
without them kind of stuff.
And I think I keep
in touch with them--
well, just speaking
as of recently, we've
done a shit ton of
screenings for the film.
We just came back
from the Middle East.
It just feels like
we're nonstop.
And to see their reactions
and to hug them and hear
their stories before,
after, during the film
is so special to me.
You know, I'm the kind of person
that will log onto my Instagram
and reply on DMs and stuff
like that, but I'm more of an
in the moment girl.
So I love seeing people, hearing
their stories face to face.
So whenever I get a chance
to do a meet and greet
or a screen viewing, I'm
just like all over that.
I'm like, yep.
[SNAPS] I'm there.
What do I wear?
Let's have fun.
SARI KATZ: What's the outfit?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah, exactly.
What's the look?
Number one.
SARI KATZ: What's the look?
And we'll talk a little bit
more about Sundance later on.
But that happened
at Sundance, right,
with the person in the audience
that raised their hand?
And where did you end up going?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yes!
OK, so really, really fast,
this is like a 20 minute story.
I'm going to make
it like, a minute.
SARI KATZ: Short story.
GIGI GORGEOUS: So we had a
question and answer moment
after the film at Sundance.
I had seen it for
the first time.
I was in a 30 pound
dress, just you know--
I had no idea what I was in for.
SARI KATZ: She's not joking.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Crying.
Like 30 pounds, like actually--
with like a slit, like a gown.
No one else was dressed up.
[LAUGHING]
My family was there.
My best friends were there.
Barbara, the
director of the film,
called everyone up on stage
for a Q&A. This young boy,
like 16 years old,
he's like, hey, I
run a GSA, a Gay Straight
Alliance, at my high school,
and not many people want to
join, and I don't know why.
What can I do to
raise more awareness?
Everyone thinks that
I'm weird at my school.
And I want the straight
people at my school
to join, to be an ally, and to
give my alliance more backing.
So I was like, well,
where do you go to school?
He's like, Malibu.
I was like, are you kidding me?
You're in Park City and
you go to school in Malibu?
I'll just come over.
I love Malibu.
[LAUGHING]
SARI KATZ: Nobu on the way.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah, right?
I was like, well, yeah, I'll
just do Nobu right after.
Like, it's so fun.
[LAUGHING]
So we ended up coordinating, and
I ended up keeping my promise.
I went over to his
school, and the school
did this whole huge assembly.
It was ridiculous.
But we had an open conversation.
And I totally saw the
energy in the room
shifting from the
beginning, because I
know like how high school is.
You want to get out
of class and like,
fuck this, whatever,
this is an assembly.
But all of them
never really cared.
And then when we
started talking,
everyone was attentive.
And we had a
question and answer.
And we had people coming
up saying, like, you know,
I'm bisexual, and
I've never really said
that ever before,
or like, you know,
I want to transition--
like really powerful stuff.
And to hear that in high school
was just so rewarding for me.
And I was just like, you know,
I want to do a school tour.
This really is everything.
This is like why I did the film.
SARI KATZ: Yeah, yeah.
And obviously there's
a lot of pressure
on you, right, as a
voice in the community.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Mhm.
SARI KATZ: Do you ever feel that
weight, being in the spotlight?
Do you ever feel like there's
things that you have to say,
things you should be saying,
things that you're not saying?
What is that like?
GIGI GORGEOUS: There's
definitely a lot of pressure.
And it sucks, because no one
should feel pressure, I feel.
You should just be able to live.
But I think that there's
a lot of pressure
right now just on anybody in the
community to know everything,
to do more.
I really never feel like I'm
doing enough or saying enough.
But at the end of
the day how I keep
my sanity is I just
speak from what I know
and what I've been through.
Because I've never really
tried to be the person
that's smarter than everybody
or trying to preach to you.
There's plenty of
other people like that.
I'm just trying to have
fun and give advice
on things that I know.
SARI KATZ: Yeah, yeah.
Share your story as a way
to inspire others and a way
to make people feel comfortable.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah.
SARI KATZ: Yeah, absolutely.
How did you make the decision
to come out on YouTube?
GIGI GORGEOUS: It was
a really hard decision.
I think my mother's passing
when I was 19 years old
was just the kind of kick in
the ass that I needed that--
it was really a
turning point for me.
If you're going to waste
days on days on days,
you're just going to
end up being unhappy.
And I knew that I
wanted to do this.
So I think after I told my close
friends and I told my family,
I really just
decided to drive it
home and go full balls
to the wall on YouTube
and just tell
everybody who I was.
Because even if I didn't talk
to them every day, even if they
were a complete stranger
to me, at least people
would know that
that's who I was.
And that's what I was talking
about earlier with holding
myself accountable.
It really did.
YouTube really-- once you
post it, it's out there.
SARI KATZ: There's
no turning back.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah,
there's no turning back.
SARI KATZ: There's
no turning back.
And we just talked
about, you don't go back
and you don't watch your videos,
but you started your channel
as Gregory.
And you've left most, if not
all, of the content up there.
Why make the decision
to leave it there?
GIGI GORGEOUS: It's so weird.
It was never really a
decision that I had to make.
I didn't really think
about, oh my god,
should I take all this down?
Because I'm not an
insecure person.
I want to leave
all that stuff up
because it makes me who I am.
And it's also-- I worked
hard on those videos.
SARI KATZ: You [INAUDIBLE].
GIGI GORGEOUS: I spent so
much time doing that shit.
SARI KATZ: Yep.
GIGI GORGEOUS: So I have
taken a few videos down
because I don't
agree with what I
was saying in them necessarily.
I can't really even remember the
videos off the top of my head,
but I know I have
taken a few down.
But all the rest are up there.
That's how I came to be.
And at the end of
the day, it's just
about being confident
and owning it.
I'm not a different person now.
I know a lot of transgender
girls, especially,
they'll go away for a
year and then come back
as a different person.
And it's like, if you need
to do that, that's fine.
But I don't think that that's
necessarily the most honest way
to be happy.
Do you know what I mean?
It's much more powerful to
just let it all hang out
and just be you.
SARI KATZ: Just let
it all hang out.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah.
SARI KATZ: No, that's great.
Again, it takes
a lot of courage.
And it just represents
who you are as a person.
What was the reception,
not just amongst your fans,
but amongst the LGBTQ community
when you did come out?
What's been the
reception like for you?
GIGI GORGEOUS: It was
really, really positive.
I think a lot of people were
kind of caught off guard.
Because I remember-- it's
honestly kind of hard
to remember, even though
it was only six years ago.
I remember a lot of people--
because I was always really,
really like beat.
My face was always done.
And I was always
in girls' clothing.
And I just had insisted, no,
I don't want to be a girl.
No I don't want
to-- because it was
something I was asked a lot.
So I think people online
and people in my real life--
like, my dad was kind of
just like, well, what?
Now you want to be?
Like, what?
That's not fair.
What are you talking about?
So I think a lot of
people were shocked.
But I think a lot of
people were happy,
just because I think they saw
that I was realizing my truth.
And I think that even if
they weren't happy about it
at first, I think in videos to
come, and in months to come,
I think they were like, oh, this
is actually who she really is.
SARI KATZ: Yeah.
And when you were growing up--
the way you represent
for young people today
a voice in the community, was
there anyone in your world,
in your universe, that sort
of represented that for you?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Honestly, no.
I think nowadays
kids have it really
hard with social media and
technology and all that stuff.
I can't even imagine growing
up nowadays in high school
and elementary school.
But I think they have it
a lot better in the sense
that they have role models like
Caitlyn Jenner and Laverne Cox
and all these
beautiful-- you know,
Ellen Degeneres was my one
person that I was like,
oh, she's gay.
And I know that she's gay.
Other than that--
but I didn't really
look up to her or
anything like that.
But I knew.
It was like something mindful.
But I think people today have
it so much easier because they
have people out there
that really fight for them
and make it--
especially transgender
people, who
have people like that to
make it a household topic.
Everyone knows what a
transgender person is nowadays.
When I was growing up,
that was not the case.
So I really didn't.
And I think kids have
it really well today
to find out who they are.
SARI KATZ: And you
started saying--
you started name
dropping some people.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yes.
SARI KATZ: What about now?
So are those some of the
people that inspire you?
Or who in the trans community
are inspirations to you
nowadays?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Well
I love Caitlyn Jenner
because she did make it
such a household topic.
I don't think
people were talking
about being transgender until
she came out, because she was
so in the spotlight
as Bruce, so everyone
was kind of like dying
over the gossip of that.
But people like Laverne Cox,
who is like truly an icon--
the "Time Magazine" cover
is just like, insane to me.
That's such an honor.
Good for her.
SARI KATZ: I remember
when you met her.
GIGI GORGEOUS: I know.
Yeah, we met her-- well,
I met her with you.
Yeah.
SARI KATZ: [INAUDIBLE] summit.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah,
she's so sweet.
Every time I've seen
her, she's so sweet.
And on social media,
she'll just shout me out.
And she's just all
about the sisterhood.
And that's how it should be.
But also Janet Mock, who
is extremely intelligent.
And she is the one to go to
if you have any questions
or whatever.
Her second book just came out.
And I have yet to read it, but
it's going to be a good read.
SARI KATZ: I'm sure it's
going to be amazing.
GIGI GORGEOUS:
Yeah, she's amazing.
She really does kill it for us.
SARI KATZ: Yep.
When you're making your videos,
are you thinking about it
from an educational perspective,
in the same way you just said,
Janet Mock, she
knows everything.
She has all the answers
to every question.
How do you approach your videos?
Is it to be educational?
Is it to be entertaining?
Is it to be both?
What are you thinking
about doing that?
GIGI GORGEOUS: I think
I'm honestly only trying
to be educational when I'm doing
a makeup video or something
like that, to be honest.
SARI KATZ: All right, OK.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Just
techniques and stuff.
But for the most part,
I'm just living my life.
Because at the end of the day,
I think that the way people get
educated-- especially
people who have a little bit
of discrimination in them
towards my community or just
of anything--
I think the best way to get them
to wrap their head around it
and to stop thinking that
way is to just be you
and maybe to add a little bit of
humor or something towards it.
Because it will lighten them up.
And it will also be like,
oh, she's a real person.
You know, I've had so
many fathers, or mothers,
or people come to me and say,
oh my my god, my daughter and I
bond watching your videos.
And initially I didn't
know what she was doing,
but now I get it.
And now I'm a fan of you
too, because it's just
like watching a real person.
It doesn't matter if I'm trans.
It doesn't matter if I'm gay.
It does not matter, because
I'm just a real person.
SARI KATZ: It's you.
GIGI GORGEOUS:
Yeah, it's the way
to educate, through
storytelling, you know?
SARI KATZ: That's right.
That's right.
So obviously June, Pride month.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yes.
SARI KATZ: You participated in
Pride in New York last year.
You did Pride in LA
this past weekend.
Obviously super fun.
GIGI GORGEOUS: So fun.
SARI KATZ: Do you remember
your first Pride experience?
GIGI GORGEOUS: I do.
It was actually with my
manager, who isn't here today.
It was in Canada.
He had an apartment there.
And I was like, I just want
to go and see the vibe.
Because I heard
it was craziness.
But I didn't know it
was as crazy as it was.
There was like-- we went.
We all got together--
him, me, and my best
friend Mark at the time.
And we just got drunk.
And we walked the streets.
And there was like,
naked men everywhere,
and just Pride flags.
But it was like
the energy has not
changed since that first Pride.
This Pride in LA--
I was hosting.
I was working.
I was on stage.
But it was just like
the same energy.
Just everyone has a smile on.
Everyone is like, you know,
just dressing how they want.
And sometimes that's an issue.
Sometimes you can't put
glitter on your face
without being stared at.
But everybody was just living
their authentic selves.
And it was just so fun.
And you really do
feel the energy.
SARI KATZ: Yeah, yeah.
Everyone's there just to live
their life, be who they are.
It's just a great experience.
That's awesome.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah.
SARI KATZ: So let's talk a
little bit about the movie.
For those of you that don't
know, as part of our YouTube
original slate this year, we
released "This Is Everything--
Gigi Gorgeous."
And Sundance-- one
thing, it premiered
as an official entrant
to Sundance 2017.
So why make the film?
Why was it important
to tell your story?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Well initially,
for anybody that's seen it,
all of the footage
that I self shot--
kind of like vlog, diary style--
all of that footage
was footage that I
planned on keeping secret.
I kept it in a vault, I like to
call it, just in my computer.
I really only made it
for myself and my friends
and my family to
show them, like,
oh my god, look what I did,
or like a video diary for me.
And then when I was done with
my transition, I was like, well,
I have all this footage.
So I talked to my team.
And I was like, I really
want to do some kind of film
or you know, a video
series or something.
And then when YouTube Red
approached us, I was like, wow,
it's getting real.
SARI KATZ: It's real.
GIGI GORGEOUS: And then when
we picked the director, Barbara
Kopple, and when she had
time and everything really
worked out perfectly.
It was fate.
It was just a thing.
So I was like, here you go.
Here's all my footage.
And then she was like,
I want you to not
see it until it's done.
I want it to be a secret,
which was really hard for me.
But my first time watching
it was at Sundance.
And it was like--
I wouldn't have
it any other way.
SARI KATZ: I remember.
I remember looking over.
Gigi was sitting a
row in front of me.
You were sitting next
to your dad and Nats.
And I just kept looking over
to see what your reaction was.
I couldn't tell though,
because I was behind.
But it was-- first time, what
was going through your head
when you were watching it?
GIGI GORGEOUS: It
was like, whoa.
It was just like a whoa moment.
Because it was a huge theater,
just a huge IMAX movie
theater, huge screen.
We were sitting right in front.
And I just remember,
when it started playing,
I was just like, oh
my god, we're here
and we're doing this.
It went by so fast.
And I don't even think that
I watched it the first time.
I think I was just looking at
how I looked, or something.
[LAUGHTER]
But the second and
third time I watched it,
I really took it in.
And I was like, oh my
god, this is done so well.
I took myself out of it and
just watched it as a stranger.
And it's crazy how much A, I
filmed, you know, B, I grew,
and just--
everything.
I don't think many
people can say
that they've seen their
entire lives in 90 minutes.
It was just like,
wow, that's me.
That's my whole life, yep.
SARI KATZ: Yep, that
was your whole life.
You really did give over
complete and total trust
to Barbara.
What was that like?
How did you let
go of the control?
GIGI GORGEOUS: I
honestly just did it
like a Band-Aid, ripped it off.
I was just like, if
she wants to do this--
and Barbara is-- she's amazing.
She is a true filmmaking artist.
And she's been
rewarded for that.
She is very successful.
SARI KATZ: Two time
Oscar-winning documentarian.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yes.
So she's a pro.
So when she said,
you know, I want
to keep this secret
from you, and I really
want to surprise
you at Sundance--
and at the time,
we didn't know we
were going to be at Sundance.
I wanted to premiere
it at Toronto.
SARI KATZ: Yeah, yeah.
GIGI GORGEOUS: But
Sundance obviously
is like, everything, so
wasn't pissed about that.
But yeah, she just
said, you know,
I really want to surprise you.
And I was just like, well,
if anyone's going to do it,
it's Barbara Kopple.
So kill it, girl.
SARI KATZ: Kill it.
GIGI GORGEOUS: And I was like,
when am I going to see it?
When is it done?
And I felt like it took forever
because I wasn't involved,
but it was worth the wait.
SARI KATZ: As someone who--
you still edit.
You still do everything
with your videos.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah.
SARI KATZ: So I can imagine
giving up that control
was probably pretty hard.
GIGI GORGEOUS: It was.
And my dad was also
in on the secret.
He was giving them home videos.
Because in the movie, I wasn't
expecting to see all of me
as a baby, or me diving.
I hadn't seen me
diving since I quit.
So I was like, where
did she get this?
And then my dad was
like, she emailed me,
and I gave it to her.
I was like, oh my god, dad.
SARI KATZ: What was the
best part of the experience?
And what was the worst
part of the experience
in making the film?
GIGI GORGEOUS: I would
say the best part is--
well, there's two best parts.
Watching it and having a movie
that documents the first 24
years of my life is the best
present I could ever get.
It's so surreal to me that
all of that was on film.
And it was edited from her.
It's just like, the best gift.
Number two is definitely
watching it with my supporters
and strangers.
I love seeing their
reactions to it.
And I love that I know now that
it's doing good in the world.
And the worst part,
I would say, for me,
is just anything to
do with my mom is just
like cringeworthy to me.
I'm still dealing
with her passing.
So it's like reliving that when
I watch it is just so hard.
I cry every single time.
SARI KATZ: Yeah, I can imagine
that's not an easy thing
to live and just
to see on a screen.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Right.
SARI KATZ: Absolutely.
There are some very personal
moments in the film.
GIGI GORGEOUS:
Mhm, yes there are.
SARI KATZ: Lots-- again--
GIGI GORGEOUS: Lots of nudity.
SARI KATZ: There's a
little bit of that.
GIGI GORGEOUS: A
SARI KATZ: How do you
feel about them now?
And how did you feel
seeing them on the screen?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Well
initially, I was
a little bit angry at
how my body was shown,
and the relationship I was in at
the time with my ex-boyfriend.
That was documented in
the film because that
was when we filmed.
So why would it not be?
But now, looking
back, it just is
like, oh my god, that
was such a mistake,
or like, ew, what
was I thinking?
Fuck my life!
[LAUGHING]
As anyone would feel, but I was
angry initially, being like,
why the hell would
she put that in?
But like, I mean,
that was my life.
It's a documentary.
You're not going to
leave everything out.
And as far as the
nudity and stuff goes,
I just feel like initially
I was like, really?
I feel like the
clip of my boobs,
when I first got them
done and they're so like--
I mean, they're just not
even boobs at that point.
It looks so swollen and crazy.
I was like, this is
like, so uncomfortable.
I was like, waiting for it
to cut to another scene,
and it just kept going.
Like fucking hell, cut it!
But it's all for the good of
the education, the documentary.
At the end of the day
it is a learning tool.
So to see the process
is interesting.
But for me, it's like,
ah, those are my boobs!
[LAUGHING]
SARI KATZ: It's true.
In the film you also
recognize, and you
say this, that you've been
really, really fortunate
in a couple of different ways.
The support of your
family and your friends
in the early parts of your
journey all the way to today.
You also said you
know that that's not
the case for a lot
of transgender youth,
who sadly sometimes go
homeless, commit suicide.
What can you do, or what do
you do, with your platform
to support those who don't have
the same support as you did?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah, that's
something in the film
that I think we could have
acknowledged actually more,
the fact that I was blessed.
I think Barbara did
a great job at that,
but I just wanted
to stress it more.
I feel like I can never stress
how blessed I was enough.
Because my dad really,
even from the beginning,
even though he wasn't
on board, he never
scolded me for who I was.
Or he never said, you can't
have this or you can't do this.
Because I was going
to do it anyways.
And he knew that.
So he was on board with
what I wanted to do.
And that's like the world's best
dad, or world's best parent.
And with my platform,
I just really,
really want to inspire people.
And I know that people are
not always as fortunate.
But I think it's not
the cards you're given.
It's what you do with
You know, I actually was
doing an interview yesterday.
And I think the person said
41% of transgender youth end
up committing suicide.
And it just is something
astronomically high like that.
And it just breaks
my heart that they--
because I've been
there, you know.
I think everybody
can relate, going
through a period in
your life where you feel
like you can't do it anymore.
But I think for
transgender people, or just
people in our community,
it's kind of amplified.
And it's not fair.
But I think, at
the end of the day,
you need to get it in your
head that you're confident,
and you're going to kill it,
and things will get better.
And that's what I plan
to do with my platform.
I always really just want
to inspire people and get
the bad talking voices
out of their head
and just let them
see the positive
and turn their lives around.
SARI KATZ: Yeah,
no, that's awesome.
Your dad is, like we said,
the star of the show.
GIGI GORGEOUS: He's an angel.
SARI KATZ: He is an angel.
And at the end of the film
he talks about, or says,
he didn't have to
learn a new person.
Gigi's heart and soul
didn't go through surgery.
I thought that was
incredibly powerful.
GIGI GORGEOUS: I know.
SARI KATZ: That was
where I really teared up.
I thought it was amazing.
And there was a really nice
scene with you and your dad
after some of your
surgeries, where he's--
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah,
I just got goosebumps!
SARI KATZ: Honestly, it's like
you don't hear that enough
in the world and the fact that
he is so incredibly supportive.
And you know, your
personality is still the same.
Your interests are
still the same.
Your hobbies are still the same.
You started your YouTube
channel doing something--
make up tutorials
and testing products.
Where do you see
your content going?
You said you're enjoying
the lifestyle stuff.
Where do you see it
going in the future?
GIGI GORGEOUS: I
actually don't know.
It's like a beautifully
unknown territory for me.
Because I think I just take
every day as another journey.
And whatever I decide to
film, or post, or not post,
it's beautifully up to me.
And it's just wherever
life takes me.
But as far as projects going,
I am the first transgender
spokesperson for
Revlon, which I'm like--
I mean, I'm dying.
SARI KATZ: Yes, yes!
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yes, Revlon!
[APPLAUSE]
So that's where I'll
be going with makeup.
And I think that's a huge--
I mean, it's not only a
sponsorship and a partnership.
It's like, an honor to
be the first transgender
spokesperson for Revlon.
I think it's a
huge step for them.
And I'm really happy about that.
SARI KATZ: Yeah.
I'm wrapping up my questions.
So start thinking.
We do have some mics, or we
have a mic floating around.
So feel free to think
of your questions
and come up and ask them.
But what-- a couple
more questions from me.
What's the experience been
like with your brothers?
Because you are-- you
and your two brothers.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yes.
SARI KATZ: And they were
also incredibly supportive.
So talk a little bit more about
your relationship with them.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Well,
my brothers and I
have always been really close.
I've always been different,
since I was a baby.
But they have really
good senses of humor.
I'm the middle child.
So I don't really know
the middle child syndrome,
but I always required
a lot of attention.
[LAUGHING]
GIGI GORGEOUS: Is that--
I don't know if that's true to--
SARI KATZ: Yeah, yeah.
GIGI GORGEOUS: It is?
OK, so yeah, middle child
through and through.
But my younger brother--
we spent a lot
more time together,
because my older brother
went away to university.
And I actually started
transitioning when
I was at home with my brother.
So he kind of saw everything.
And he knows all of like, the
surgery aspects and everything
like that.
And I was actually
really surprised
to see that they were
included in the documentary
as much as they were.
And the fact that--
I think with your family, and
with my brothers and my father,
just talking about
them as a whole,
I hadn't heard from their
mouths a lot of the things
that they said.
Like my brother saying,
Gigi is transgender.
It's as if she made up the term.
That is her.
Like, I had never
heard him say that.
And especially like, my dad
and Adam, my older brother,
crying on camera, I was just
like, oh, my god, they like,
really love me.
And just like-- I don't
know, hearing that--
I don't know if it was
Barbara's magic or what,
but they really opened up.
And to watch them
say those things,
and to have that on camera
and as a film as a whole,
I think it just speaks to how
lucky I am with my family.
Like, I have the best family.
SARI KATZ: You do.
The movie is a lot--
obviously, it's your
journey and it's your story.
But there's so much
love in the film.
And I'd only seen it at Sundance
for the first time, too.
I wanted to wait.
And I was really, really
surprised by that.
I didn't expect it.
So again, if you haven't
seen it, watch the movie.
It's amazing.
GIGI GORGEOUS: We're
up for an Emmy.
Well--
SARI KATZ: Consideration.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Consideration.
SARI KATZ: Consideration
for an Emmy.
GIGI GORGEOUS: But good vibes.
We're putting out
there that we are.
SARI KATZ: Good
vibes in the world.
Good vibes in the world.
But it was nominated
for an MTV movie award.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yes.
SARI KATZ: I know
we didn't win, but--
GIGI GORGEOUS: Who
ended up winning that?
SARI KATZ: I don't even know.
I don't even know.
GIGI GORGEOUS: It was rigged.
SARI KATZ: Adam, do you know?
I don't even know.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Rigged!
SARI KATZ: But again,
fingers crossed, Emmys,
fingers crossed.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Fingers crossed.
SARI KATZ: But those are
the questions I have.
I hope people in the
audience have some questions.
Yes, we've got one over here.
AUDIENCE: First of
all, thanks for coming.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Love the talk so far.
So part of our theme for
Pride this year at Google
is about showing up.
So what would you say
to folks in the audience
or on live stream about showing
up for the trans community?
Or what are ways you would
say we could be the strongest
allies to the trans community?
GIGI GORGEOUS: I
saw so many allies
when I was hosting Pride in LA.
And even in the Middle East,
when I was in Tel Aviv,
I just saw so much love
and support from allies.
I think being there, especially
right now, during that time
that we're in, I think
coming out during Pride month
and really sharing everything
on your social media, showing up
is--
I love that you guys are
doing that, by the way.
Showing up is like, half the
battle in life-- you know,
for jobs or whatever.
It's just showing up.
So showing--
[LAUGHING]
Like, duh.
But yeah, I'd
honestly just be like,
go out to everything
gay this summer.
[LAUGHING]
Right?
I mean, I don't know
what else to say.
Sorry.
SARI KATZ: It's true.
Just being present and being
there is half the battle.
I like that.
Questions?
Yeah, over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Gigi.
Thanks so much for being
here, first of all.
I actually got to see
the film yesterday.
It was really cool to
follow your whole journey
and everything.
So thank you for
putting that out there.
I'm curious, what would you
say to a transgender person who
either doesn't have access to
the same kind of transition
or maybe doesn't even want
to go through the same kind
of transition, or even someone
who identifies as non-binary
or something like that?
And what can we do to
fight for more acceptance
of those identities and images?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Well
first, thank you so much.
I really hope you
enjoyed the film.
And of course, I'm happy
to be here talking.
I would say being non-binary,
identifying as that,
is kind of something new to me.
I'm meeting a lot more
people that identify as that.
And it's really interesting.
And you know, I don't shy
away from asking questions
or anything like that.
I don't think it's rude.
I think that they
enjoy talking about it.
I think a lot of people
have that kind of like, uh,
should I--
is it rude?
But like, how else
are you going to know?
I would say, just to
pivot for one second,
I remember when I transitioned
I would tell people, I'm trans.
And I really would love for
you to call me she and her
and use the name Gigi.
And a lot of people
would slip up.
And they wouldn't even--
I think I see a lot of
people doing it with Caitlyn.
You know, they'll slip
up and say, Bruce and he,
and then they'll just
go on with their day.
It's like, no, that's not OK.
You need to definitely be on it.
And I think that's one
way to give confidence
to a lot of people.
If you're trans, and
you're being acknowledged
how you want to be acknowledged,
it is literally just the best
compliment.
You're giving an
unsaid compliment.
And I think for people who
are non-binary, hearing they
and them is so
reassuring to them.
And it's just like,
I can do this.
I'm around comfortable people.
I don't have to like,
cringe or worry, you know?
So I would say
allies also can help
in this, because they're the
ones who we want support from.
Another transgender woman, at
the beginning of my transition,
saying she and Gigi to
me wasn't as fulfilling
as my father or my
brother saying it.
So I think allies
can just support
and be overly supportive.
Just give them everything.
Make them feel good
about themselves.
SARI KATZ: Yep, cool.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I think everyone
in the LGBT community
has definitely had a really
rough point in their life.
And I was wondering
for you, what
was your biggest motivation to
get through those rough points?
GIGI GORGEOUS: My
biggest motivation--
I had a few.
My supporters for
sure, because I
knew that I had to be
held accountable for them
and from them.
Also my mom-- knowing
that I could--
one of my biggest
regrets in my life
is not being able to say
to her that I was trans
while she was still alive.
And I knew it was
going on in my head.
I just couldn't work up
the courage to do so.
So I think wanting to do that
is obviously something, 100%.
But she keeps me going.
I think about, what
would my mom do?
Or you know, I'm going
to do this for her,
or I wasn't strong
enough in that moment,
so I'm going to be
strong enough now.
It was definitely a
huge reminder to me.
It's a reminder to me everyday.
SARI KATZ: Any other
questions in the room?
Yeah, over here.
Oh, one there and then one here.
AUDIENCE: So what would
you say to someone
in the queer
community that's just
starting out and trying
to find their voice
and build a platform possibly?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Well that's
a really good question.
I don't even know if I
can answer that fully.
If you're trying to
build a presence online,
I would say being
consistent is number one.
So maybe having a
few ideas on the go
and having a couple of
things like back in the vault
that you can really
put out there
to keep people interested.
Because there are so
many people online.
But as for real life, if I'm
understanding the question
correctly, I think just being
present as your authentic self.
Even if you are searching for
something else, even though--
if you don't know
if you're trans yet,
or you don't want to go
through with it, whatever.
I think just living as
you are right that second
and waking up every day with
a really, really strong sense
of self.
Because I think that will exude.
And other people
will catch the drift.
And other people will be
inspired by your confidence.
SARI KATZ: Maybe one over here.
AUDIENCE: We're just--
[LAUGHS]
GIGI GORGEOUS: Bad mic.
AUDIENCE: We're just starting to
see depictions of us in media--
I mean, fictional ones.
Is there a favorite character,
trans character, in media
that inspires you?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Hm,
that's a good one.
I love Zachary
from "Transparent."
I don't know.
I don't know if
that's my favorite.
It's hard to say.
Good question.
It's such a cop
out, but honestly, I
feel like Caitlyn
is my favorite.
I was just such a fan of
the Kardashians before.
So to see her transition,
and how good she looks,
I just am such a fan.
I'm rooting for her.
I have a lot to thank for her.
And so does the community.
So maybe she's my favorite.
Maybe not.
I don't know.
I'm my favorite.
I'm just kidding.
[LAUGHING]
SARI KATZ: Yeah, over here?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So I've been following
you on YouTube,
like totally from the beginning.
And I know you've come
out a few different times,
in different capacities,
on your channel.
And I'm sure for
people that are not
as connected to the
LGBTQ community, that
can be kind of
confusing, and they
might have a lot of
questions about how
you've got to the fully realized
person you are right now.
So what do you think is
the most important thing
for outside people to
realize about that very
personal journey of
continually discovering
yourself and finding your
truth at the end of the day?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah,
I think it's an--
yes, I have come out
more than once online.
And it's kind of a
question I get a lot,
but I take it with humor.
Because I have been online
for a very long time.
And I think people
realized a lot of things.
You know that Kylie Jenner meme?
This year I'm just realizing
a lot of stuff, or whatever.
[LAUGHING]
It's true.
I look at my YouTube as
literally a diary of like,
how I'm changing.
And a year is a
really long time.
So I think for me to be online
now for seven years, it's like,
of course I'm a different
person than when I started.
So I think that just is--
it speaks to, and I
think it's inspiring
of people, to be like,
look at her way back then.
She is so much different now.
Like, almost
anything is possible.
Because you know, I've
experienced things
and said things that I
never thought that I would.
And you know, who
knows what I'll
be saying or doing next year?
You never know, you know?
So I think it just
speaks to authenticity.
And authenticity comes
in many shapes and forms.
And people realize
stuff all the time.
I don't know.
SARI KATZ: I think it speaks
to what you just said before
to the other question.
It's like you wake up every
day, and you live your truth
in the moment.
And you're allowed-- your
truth and who you are
is allowed to be fluid and
it's allowed to change.
And as long as you
are recognizing
that you are being
true to yourself
and being true to your
audience, that's OK.
And I think that's an
important thing to recognize.
And again, not many
people are held
accountable in the same
sense that you are.
Everything's out there.
And there's a lot of questions,
because it remains out there,
which I think takes
a lot of courage,
and you should be very proud.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Thank you.
Yeah, YouTube definitely
holds you accountable.
If you post something-- girl.
Even if you delete
it, it's like, someone
is going to have that footage
somewhere, or someone's going
to rip it and post it again
or something, you know?
So it's like, you need
to know who you are.
And it's good, because it's made
me realize my authentic self.
And it's like, I don't know
if I would have been here
without YouTube.
SARI KATZ: We're glad
that we could support you.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yes.
SARI KATZ: If there are
no-- oh, one more question.
One more question, great.
AUDIENCE: Hey Gigi.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Hey.
AUDIENCE: I'm Ricardo.
Thank you so much
for being here.
So when we talk about Pride, we
often talk about celebrations.
But as many of us know,
the first Pride march
wasn't just about celebration.
And especially today, with
the political atmosphere,
there's a little more anger,
and resentment, and resistance.
So what would you say is the
balance that we should strike
between being happy, and proud,
and celebrating all that we've
done, but acknowledging
the work that we need to do
and why we need to speak up?
GIGI GORGEOUS: Good question.
Honestly, I don't know if
this is the right answer,
but I feel like celebrating
is almost the same
as fighting back.
Because when you're out and
you're having a good time
and we're all together, it's
almost like the biggest eff
you to society.
And I know the Pulse Orlando
massacre a few days ago
celebrated the one year.
And my girlfriend actually
did something super special.
We went there and we held a kind
of like a little mini event.
And it was so powerful.
And even that was really,
really dark and emotional.
But I feel like we were
celebrating our community
and that we are still here.
And you know, the
night club was lined
with a fence with roses and
just so much love, objects
of love and light.
And I think celebrating,
especially this month
in particular, I think it's the
most important month for us.
I think showing up,
celebrating, having
fun, go have a drink with your
friends, go to this event,
take pictures, post
online that you're there
and that you support.
And I think that's
fighting in a way.
SARI KATZ: Well thank you
so much everyone for coming.
And a huge thank you to Gigi
for being here with Talks
at Google.
And again, if you have not seen
her film, "This Is Everything--
Gigi Gorgeous."
You can watch it on YouTube Red.
GIGI GORGEOUS: YouTube Red.
SARI KATZ: YouTube Red!
GIGI GORGEOUS: Huge
shout out to YouTube Red.
Thank you for all that they do.
SARI KATZ: And again, thank you
so much for being here, Gigi.
GIGI GORGEOUS: Yeah, thanks.
[CHEERING]
Yes, thanks for having me.
[APPLAUSE]